ici aussi on en a été colonisée avant
par les les anglais et du coup il y
avait une similarité entre les deux
histoires
j'ai lu les belles soeurs de michel
tremblay et donc ça c'était le coup de
foudre et j'ai donc décidé de me lancer
dans les études québécoises
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au détour d'un corridor de l'université
jawaharlal nehru de la capitale indienne
je n'en croyais pas mes yeux une salle
québec la classe en porte le nom mais
aussi la couleur à l'intérieur on
retrouve une partie des 2000 livres
québécois que possède l'université vie
jahia raho et enseigne la littérature
québécoise depuis 26 ans la partie la
plus importante sur lequel on concentre
c'est plutôt les années 60 70
pendant la révolution tranquille avec
cette littérature effervescente mais
aussi des textes plus récents ou même la
bande dessinée oui les classiques les
incontournables sont là évidemment il ya
miron il ya un ibère mais aussi du
charme il ya tremblé
anne hébert gabrielle roy et nelly arcan
sont les auteurs les plus populaires
chez la vingtaine d'étudiants inscrits
chaque année à ses cours les étudiants
quand ils viennent chez nous ils ont 18
ans il s'appelle mot de français et
pendant trois ans et 20 ans par semaine
il ya des cours intensifs d'abord
uniquement sur la langue et après en
deuxième année 3 et menez introduit
d'autres coûts par exemple un boss
l'histoire la géographie le cours sur
l'histoire du québec débute avec les
explorateurs tombé sur la nouvelle
france en cherchant la route des indes
ce qui fait bien rire les étudiants le
cours aborde aussi les deux référendums
sur la souveraineté et les débats
contemporains au québec comme les
relations entre les communautés
culturelles
certains textes sont difficiles donc on
fait un choix aussi par exemple les
textes tremblay enfin les textes les
pièces de théâtre des années soixante et
soixante dix un surtout qu'ils étaient
plus pluton joêl ça pose problème mais
on tient quand même à faire découvrir
ces textes là pour les étudiants et une
idée de comment la langue dit faire un
tendre à l'autre tout en sachant que
c'était une période qui avait marqué une
certaine identité une carte d'identité
déjà une quinzaine de thèse sur le
québec ont été soutenus en inde ou sont
en cours de préparation
c'est le cas des doctorantes n'aidera ni
micha et rouch ira je travaillais sur la
symbolisation des cloches et kamouraska
qui écrit par anne hébert
j'ai choisi le roman de 5 6 étoiles de
mon époux et lilies c'est le flux est de
michel marc bouchard
je travaille sur le phénomène de longues
racines errance qui est un concept
jean-claude chasse un écrivain haïtien
et je travaille sur ce phénomène dont
les ouvrages de lynch aîné de kim thuy à
travers la littérature
ces étudiantes indiennes ont le
sentiment de connaître le québec même si
elles n'y ont jamais mis les pieds
je trouve que l'écriture la basse et
plus fraîche et aux signatures d'espoir
dans ses plumes que dans l'écriture des
romans l'hexagone
[Musique]